ladies and gentlemen
the president of the united states
been a long day for y'all i know it was
easy getting into the uh
the pre-meeting there was no problem
getting through those doors was it
was there anyway hello everyone
uh well
i've just finished the uh the last
meeting
of this week's long trip uh
the u.s russian summit and i know there
were a lot of hype around this meeting
but it's pretty straightforward to me
the meeting
one there's no substitute as those of
you who have covered me for a while know
for face-to-face dialogue between
leaders none
and president putin and i had a
share unique responsibility to manage
the relationship between two powerful
and proud countries
a relationship that has to be stable
and predictable and it should be able to
we should be able to cooperate where
it's in our mutual interest
and where we have differences i want to
president putin understand
why i say what i say and why
i do what i do and how we'll respond
to specific to specific kinds of actions
that harm america's interest
now i told president putin my agenda is
not against
russia or anyone else it's
for the american people fighting kova 19
rebuilding our economy reestablishing
relationships around the world our
allies and friends
and protecting the american people
that's my
responsibility as president i also told
them that no
president of the united states could
keep faith with the american people
if they did not speak out to defend our
democratic values
to stand up for the universal and
fundamental freedoms that all men and
women
have in our view that's just part of the
dna of our country
so human rights is going to always be on
the table i told them
it's not about just going after russia
when they violate human rights
it's about who we are how could i be the
president of the united states of
america
and not speak out against the violation
of human rights i told him
that unlike other countries including
russia
we're uniquely a product of an idea
you've heard me say this before again
and again
but i'm going to keep saying it what's
that idea
we don't derive our rights from the
government
we possess them because we're born
period and we yield them to a government
and so the forum i pointed out to him
that
that's why we're going to raise our
concerns about cases like alexi navalny
i made it clear to president putin that
we'll continue to raise
issues of fundamental human rights
because that's
what we are that's who we are the idea
is we hold these true self-evident
but all men and women we haven't lived
up to it completely but we've always
widened the arc of commitment
and included more and more people and i
raised the case
of two wrongfully imprisoned american
citizens paul whalen and trevor reed
i also raised the ability of radio free
europa ready liberty to operate
and the importance of a free press and
freedom of speech
i made it clear that we will not
tolerate attempts to violate our
democratic sovereignty
or destabilize our democratic elections
and we would respond
the bottom line is i told president
putin that we need to have some basic
rules of the road
that we can all abide by i also said
they're areas where
there's a mutual interest for us to
cooperate
for our people russian and american
people
but also for the benefit of the world
and the security of the world
one of those areas is strategic
stability
you asked me many times what was i going
to discuss with putin before i came i
told you i only negotiate with the
individual and now i can tell you
what i was intending to do all along
and that is to discuss and raise the
issue of strategic stability
and try to set up a mechanism where we
dealt with it
we discussed in detail the next steps
our country should take
on arms control measures the steps we
need to take to reduce the
risk of unintended conflict and i'm
pleased he agreed today
to launch a bilateral strategic
stability dialogue
diplomatic speak for saying get our
military experts and our
our diplomats together to work in a
mechanism that can lead
to control of new and dangerous and
sophisticated weapons that are coming
on the scene now that reduce the times
of response
that raise the prospects of accidental
war
and we went into some detail of what
those weapons systems were
another area we spent a great deal of
time on was cyber
and cyber security i talked about the
proposition that certain critical
infrastructures should be off
limits to attack period by cyber or any
other means i gave them a list
if i'm not mistaken i don't have it in
front of me 16
specific entities 16 defined as
critical infrastructure under u.s policy
from the energy sector to our water
systems
of course the principle is one thing
it has to be backed up by practice
responsible countries need to take
action against criminals
who conduct ransomware activities on
their territory
so we agreed to task experts
in both our both our countries to work
on specific understandings
about what's off limits and to follow up
on specific
cases that originate in other countries
and they're either our countries there's
a long list of other things we spent
time on
from the urgent need to preserve and
reopen the humanitarian carters in syria
so that we can get food just simple food
and basic necessities
the people who are starving to death how
to build it
and and how it is in the interest of
both rushing the united states
to ensure that iran iran does not
acquire nuclear weapons we agreed to
work together there because as much as
russia's interest is ours and to how we
can ensure the arctic remains and that
region of cooperation rather than
conflict
i caught part of president uh trump uh
putin's uh uh press conference and he
talked about the need for us to
be able to have some kind of modus
operandi where he dealt with
making sure the arctic was in fact a
free zone
and to how we can each contribute to the
shared effort of preventing the
resurgence of terrorism in afghanistan
it's very much in
in the interest of russia not to have a
resurgence of terrorism afghanistan
are also areas that are more challenging
i communicated the united states
unwavering commitment to the
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
ukraine
we agreed to pursue diplomacy related to
the minx agreement
and i shared our concern about belarus
he didn't disagree with what happened he
just has a different perspective of what
to do about it
but i know you have a lot of questions
so let me
close with this it was important to meet
in person
so there can be no mistake about or
misrepresentations
about what i wanted to communicate i did
what i came to do
number one identify areas of practical
work
our two countries can do to advance our
mutual interest
and also benefit the world two
communicate directly directly that the
united states will respond to actions
that impair our vital interests
or those of our allies and three to
clearly lay out our country's priorities
and our values
so we heard it straight from me and i
must tell you
the tone of the entire meetings i guess
it was a total of four hours
was was what was was good positive
there wasn't any any strident action
taken well we disagreed i disagreed
stayed at where it was he disagreed he
stated
but it was not done in a hyperbolic
atmosphere
that is too much of what's been going on
over this last week
i believe i hope the united states has
shown the world
that we are back standing with our
allies
we rallied our fellow democracies to
make concert
commit concerted commitments to take on
the biggest challenges our world faces
and now we've established a clear basis
on how we intend to deal with russia
and the u.s russian relationship there's
much more work ahead i'm not suggesting
any of this is done
we've gotten a lot of business done on
this trip
and before i take your questions i want
to say one last thing
folks look this is about
this is about how we move from here
this is i listened to again a
significant portion of what president
putin's press conference was
and as he pointed out this is about
practical straightforward no-nonsense
decisions that we have to make or not
make
we'll find out within the next six
months to a year whether or not
we actually have a strategic dialogue
that matters we'll find out
whether we work to deal with everything
from
release of people in in
russian prisons or not we'll find out
whether we have a cyber security
arrangement that begins to bring some
order
because look the countries that most are
likely to be damaged failure to do that
are the major countries for example when
i talked about the pipeline
that cyber hit for 5 million that
ransomware hit in the united states
i looked at him and said how would you
feel if ransomware took on the pipelines
from your oil fields
he said it would matter this is not
about just our self-interest
it's about a mutual self-interest i'll
take your questions and as usual folks
they gave me a list
of the people i'm going to call on so
jonathan associated press
thank you sir uh u.s intelligence has
said that russia tried to interfere in
the last two presidential elections
and that russia groups are behind hacks
like solar winds and some of the
ransomware attacks you just mentioned
putin in his news conference just now
accepted no responsibility for any
misbehavior
your predecessor opted not to demand
that putin stop these disruptions
so what is something that concrete sir
that you achieve today
to prevent that from happening again and
what were the consequences you
threatened
whether i stopped it from happening
again
he knows i will take action like we did
when this last time out what happened
was
we in fact made it clear that we were
not going to continue to allow this to
go on
the end result was we ended up
withdrawing them they went
join ambassadors we closed down some of
their facilities in the united states
etc
he knows their consequences now look one
of the consequences
that i know i don't know i shouldn't say
that's unfair of me
i suspect you may all think doesn't
matter but i'm confidence matters to him
a confident matter to him
and other world leaders of big nations
his credibility worldwide shrinks
let's get this straight how would it be
if the united states were viewed by the
rest of the world
as interfering with the elections
directly of other countries
and everybody knew it what would it be
like
if we engage in activities that he is
engaged in
it diminishes the standing of a country
that is desperately trying to make sure
it maintains its standing
as a major world power and so it's not
just what i do
it's what the actions that other
countries take in this case russia
that are contrary to international norms
it's the price they pay
they are not they are not able to
dictate what happens in the world
there are other nations of significant
consequence i.e the united states of
america being one of them
mr president just a quick follow on the
same theme of consequences you said just
now that you spoke to
him a lot about human rights what did
you say would happen if opposition later
alexis navalny dies
i made it clear to him that i believe
the
the consequences of that would be
devastating
for russia i'll go back to the same
point what do you think happens
when he's saying it's not about hurting
the volunteers
all the stuff he says to rationalize the
treatment of navalny
and then he dies in prison
i pointed out to him that it matters a
great deal
when a country in fact and they asked me
why i thought it was important to
to continue to have problems with the
president of syria
i said because it's a violation
international norm
it's called a chemical weapons treaty
can't be trusted
it's about trust it's about their
ability to influence other
nations in a positive way look
would you like to trade our economy for
russia's economy
would you like to trade and by the way
we talked about trade
i don't have any problem with doing
business with russia as long as they do
it based upon
international norms it's in our interest
to see the russian people do well
economically i don't have a problem with
that but
if they do not act according to national
norms
then guess what that will not only
happen with us
it will not happen with other nations
and he kind of talked about that didn't
he today about how
the need to reach out other countries to
invest in russia
they won't as long as they
are convinced that in fact the
violations for example
the american businessman who was in
house arrest and
i pointed out you want to get american
business to invest
let him go change the dynamic
because american businessmen they're not
we're ready to show up they
they don't want to hang around in moscow
i mean i look guys
i know we make foreign policy out to be
this great great skill
that somehow is sort of like a secret
code
pract all foreign policies is a logical
extension of personal relationships
it's the way human nature functions and
understand
when you run a country that does not
abide by international norms and yet you
need those international norms
to be somehow managed so that you can
participate in the benefit to flow from
them
it hurts you that's not a satisfying
answer
biden said he'd invade russia you know
it's not you know
by the way that was a joke that's not
true
but my generic point is it is it is is
more complicated than that
um david sanger
i thought i just saw david there he is
thank you mr president um in the run-up
to this
uh discussion there's been a lot of talk
about the two countries
spilling down into a into a cold war and
i'm wondering if there was anything that
you
emerged from in the discussion that made
you think that
i'm gonna take my coat off the sun is
hot
anything that would make you think that
mr putin has
decided to move away from his
fundamental role as a disrupter
uh particularly a disruptor of nato in
the united states
and if i could also just follow up on
your description of how you gave him a
list
of critical infrastructure in the united
states did you lay out
very clearly what it was that the
penalty would be for interfering in that
critical infrastructure did you leave
that vague did he respond in any way to
it
let me answer your first i'll ask your
second question first
i pointed out to him we have significant
cyber capability and he knows he doesn't
know exactly what it is but it's
significant
and if in fact they violate these basic
norms
we will respond cyber
he knows in the cyber way
number two i uh i think that
the last thing he wants now is the cold
war
without quoting him which i don't think
is appropriate let me ask a rhetorical
question
you got a multi-thousand-mile border
with china
china's moving ahead hell-bent on
election as they say
seeking to be the most powerful economy
in the world the largest
and most powerful military in the world
you're in a situation where your economy
is struggling
you need to move it in a more
aggressive way than in terms of growing
it
and uh you uh
i don't think he's looking for a cold
war with the united states
i don't think it's about a as i said to
him i said your generation of mine are
about 10 years apart
this is not a kumbaya moment as you used
to say back in the 60s in the united
states like
let's hug and love each other but it's
clearly not in anybody's interest
your countries are mine for us to be in
a situation where we're in a new cold
war
and i truly believe he thinks that he
understands that
but that does not mean he's ready to
quote figured legit and lay down his
arms and say
come on he still i believe is concerned
about being quote encircled
he still is concerned that we in fact
are looking to take him down etc he
still has those concerns
but i don't think they are the driving
force it's the kind of relationship he's
looking for with the united states
um jennifer jennifer
oh jacobs thank you mr president um is
there a particular reason why the summit
lasted only about three hours we know
you had maybe a lot of four to five
hours was there any reason it ran
shorter
um also did president putin said that
there were no
threats or scare tactics issued do you
agree with that assessment that there
were no threats or scare
tactics and also did you touch on
afghanistan and the safe withdrawal
of troops yes yes yes and yes
let me uh go back to the first part uh
the reason it didn't go longer is when
the last time two heads of state have
spent over two
hours in direct conversation across the
table
going into excruciating detail
you may know of time i don't i can't
think of one
so we didn't need as we got through when
we brought in the larger group our
our defense our intelligence and our
forum well
our my foreign minister wasn't for our
minister my secretary of state was
with me the whole time our ambassador et
cetera we brought everybody in
we had covered so much and so there was
a summary done by him and by me of what
we covered
labaroth and lincoln talked about what
we had covered
we raised things that required more
amplification or
made sure we didn't have any
misunderstandings and uh
and so it was uh that it was kind of
after two hours there we looked at each
other like
okay what next
what is going to happen next is we're
going to be able to look back
look ahead in three to six months and
say
did the things we agreed to sit down and
try to work out did it work
do we are we closer to a major strategic
stability talks and and progress
are we further along in terms of them go
down the line that's going to be the
test i'm not sitting here saying because
the president and i agreed that we would
do these things that all of a sudden
it's going to work
i'm not saying that what i'm saying is i
think there's a genuine prospect
to significantly improve the relations
between our two countries
without us giving up a single solitary
thing based on principle
and our values no no no
no there were no threats there were as a
matter of fact uh
um i heard he quoted my mom and quoted
other people today
there was it was very as we say which
will shock you coming from me somewhat
colloquial
um and we talked about basic basic
fundamental things it was a
it was and you know how i am i explain
things based on personal basis
what happens if for example and so
there are no threats just there's simple
assertions
made and no well if you do that then
we'll do this
with anything i said it was just letting
him know where i stood
what i thought we could accomplish
together and what in fact if it was
if there were violations of american
sovereignty what we would do
he asked us about afghanistan he said
that he hopes that we're able to
maintain some peace and security and i
said that has a lot to do with
you he indicated that he was prepared to
quote
help on afghanistan i won't go into
detail now and help
on on on iran and help
on in return we told a lot what we
wanted to do relative to bringing some
stability
and economic security our physical
security to the people of
syria and libya so we had those
discussions
um uh yamiche
thanks so much mr president um did you
say that you didn't issue any threats
were there any ultimatums made when it
comes to ransomware
and how will you measure success
especially when it comes to these
working groups on
on russian meddling and on cyber
security well
it's going to be real easy they either
for example on
on cyber security are we going to work
out where they take action against the
ransomware
criminals on russian territory they
didn't do it
i don't think they planned it in this
case and
are they going to act we'll find out
will we commit
what can we commit to act in terms of
anything affecting
the violating international norms that
negatively affects
russia what are we going to agree to do
and so i i think we have
real opportunities to to move and i
think that
one of the things that i noticed when we
had the larger meat
is that people who are very very well
informed
started thinking you know
this could be a real problem what
happens that ransom fair outfit were
sitting in florida or maine and took
action as i said
on their their their single lifeline to
their economy
oil it'd be devastating and they're like
you could see them kind of go
oh we'd do that but like whoa
so it's it's and everybody's interested
these things be active now we'll see
though
what happens from these groups we put
together um
the third one yes go ahead um mr
president
when president putin was questioned
today about human rights he said the
reason why he's cracking down on
opposition leaders
um is because he doesn't want something
like january 6 to happen in russia and
he also said he doesn't want to see
groups formed like black lives matter
what's your response to that please
my response is kind of what i
communicated
but i think that's a uh that's a
ridiculous comparison
it's one thing for literally criminals
to break through cordon go into the
capitol
kill a police officer and be held
unaccountable
and it is for people objecting and
marching
on a capital one saying you are not
allowing me to speak freely
you are not allowing me to do a b c or d
and so they're very different criteria
um
steve steve holland reuters
president sorry president putin said he
was satisfied with the answer
about your comment about him being a
killer
could you give us your side on this what
did you tell him
he's satisfied why would i bring it up
again
now that you talk to him do you believe
you can trust him
look this is not about trust
this is about self-interest and
verification of self-interest
that's what it's about so i uh
virtually almost almost anyone
that i would work out an agreement with
that affected the american people's
interest
i don't say well i trust you no problem
let's see what happens
you know as that all expression goes the
proof of the pudding's in the eating
we're gonna know shortly um igor
radio free europe and radio liberty
hello mr president
hello mr you want to go on the shade you
can't can you see thank you yeah
yeah yeah yeah uh so
uh i think you know attacks in uh civil
society
and uh the free free press continue
inside russia yes
uh for example radio free europe yes
radio liberty voice of america
current time tv channel where i work uh
brand the foreign agents uh
and several other independent media so
uh we are essentially being forced out
in
russia 30 years after president yeltsin
invited us in my question is after
your talks with president putin
how interested do you think he's in
improving
the media climate in russia
i wouldn't put it that way in terms of
improving the climate
i would in fact put it in terms of
how much interest does he have in
burnishing russia's reputation
that is not as viewed as not being
contrary to democratic principles of
free speech
that's a judgment i cannot make i don't
know
but it's not because i think he uh he's
interested in
changing the nature of a closed
society or close government's actions
relative to
what he thinks is the right of
government to do what it
does it's a very different uh
um approach uh and uh you know there's a
couple
really good biography i told him i read
a couple i read most everything he's
written
and the speeches he's made and uh and
i've uh
read a couple very good biographies
which many of you have as well
and i think i pointed out to him that um
russia had an opportunity that brief
shining moment
after gorbachev and after things began
to
change drastically to actually generate
a democratic government
but what happened was it failed and
there was a great
great uh
race among russian intellectuals
to determine what form of government
would they choose
and how would they choose it and based
on
what i believe mr putin decided was
that russia has always been
a major international power when it's
been totally united
as a russian state not based on ideology
whether it was going back to czar and
commissar straight through
to the the revolution the russian
revolution
uh and to where they are today
and i think that it's clear to me and
i've said it that i think he decided
that
a way for russia to be able to sustain
itself as a great
quote great power is to in fact
unite the russian people on just the
strength of the government the
government controls
not necessarily ideologically but the
government and
i think that's the that's the choice
that was made
i think it i i'm not going to
second-guess
whether it could have been fundamentally
different
but i do think it does not lend itself
to
russia maintaining itself as one of the
great powers in the world
today did you in terms of the red lines
that you laid down
is military response an option for a
ransomware attack
and president putin had called you
in his press conference an experienced
person you famously
told him he didn't have a soul do you
now have a deeper
understanding of him after this meeting
thank you very much but on the military
military response no we didn't talk
about military responses for face for
face-to-face
dialogue and also with what you said at
nato that the biggest problems right now
are russia and china you've spoken many
times about how you've spent
perhaps more time with president xi than
any other
world leader so is there going to become
a time where you might call him
old friend old friend and ask him to
open up china
to the world health organization
investigators who are trying to get to
the bottom of
kovan 19. let's get something straight
we know each other well we're not old
friends
it's just pure business so i guess my
question would be
you've said that you were going to press
china you signed on to the
g7 communique that said you put the g7
were calling on china to open up
to let the investigators in but china
basically says they don't want to be
interfered with anymore so what happens
now
the impact the world's attitude toward
china as it develops john is trying very
hard
to project itself as a responsible
and very very forthcoming nation
that they are trying very hard to talk
about how they're taking and
helping the world in terms of cover 19
and vaccines
and they're trying very hard look
certain things
you don't have to explain to the people
of the world
they see the results is china really
actually trying to get to the bottom of
this one thing we did discuss
as i told you in the eu and at the
g7 and with nato what we should be doing
and what i'm going to
make an effort to do is rally the
world to work on what is going to be the
physical mechanism available to detect
early on
the next pandemic and have a mechanism
by which we can respond to it
and respond to it early it's going to
happen it's going to happen
we need to do that thank you
i am
but given his past behavior has not
changed and in that press conference
after sitting down with you
for several hours he denied any
involvement in cyber attacks
he downplayed human rights abuses he
even refused to say
alexi navalny's name so how does that
count to a constructive meeting as
president president
oh
you